hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the history
and family tree of the black family you
might not know this but Sirius Black was
more than just a powerful wizard who
escaped The Dungeons of Azkaban by
Birthright he was a member of one of the
most powerful Wizarding families in all
of Britain in fact the black family line
can be traced back through the centuries
and was celebrated as one of the
proudest pureblood families in the world
and by the time Sirius was born he was
one of the few male heirs that remained
which meant his passing in the death
chamber on Ninth level of the ministry
of magic marked the end of the black
family line but even that wasn't really
the end for them although the women of
the family didn't typically keep their
last name after marriage they married
into dozens of other purebred families
throughout England in some way almost
every Weasley Potter Lestrange Lupine
and Malfoy could find a connection to
the blacks today we're going to take a
look at the very first recorded ancestor
in sirius's line and traced the history
of the black family from sirius's own
namesake to the final male heirs if you
take one look at the Black family tree
you'll notice that the first recorded
Generations lists five members who lived
around the early 19th century although
the film version of the blacks ancestry
goes further back in time the official
Canon which JK Rowling has referenced in
her work begins here for the remainder
of this family tree I've tried to stick
as much as possible to JK Rowling's
referenced version but at times it was
impossible to separate them the first
name on the list is Sirius Black after
whom Harry Potter's godfather was later
named this Sirius Black was born in the
year 1845. like everyone else in the
black family young Sirius was a proudly
pure blood wizard but unlike other
members of his family his life was cut
tragically short in the year 1853 the
history books revealed that Sirius died
at the age of eight while it's tempting
to point out that many children died
prematurely before the rise of modern
medicine that was rarely the case in The
Wizarding World thanks to their Mastery
of potions and herbology wizards were
capable of healing almost any ailment
which means the cause of this serious
Black's death might not have been an
accident Sirius was survived by three
other siblings all born after Sirius the
first a boy named Phineas nigella's
black was born in 1847 and became one of
the most influential members of the
family to ever live as most blacks would
Phineas attended Hogwarts and once of
course placed into house Slytherin
Phineas was also very vocal in carrying
on another family tradition his hatred
for Muggles and mudbloods after he
graduated from Hogwarts around the year
1865 the Phineas married Ursula Flint
together they had five children as a
tribute to his older brother Phineas
named his first child my son Sirius and
to carry on his own name he gave the
next boy his own as Phineas black the
second when we talk about the next
generation of the black family line
we'll see that even at this point the
harsh rhetoric around mudbloods would
take its toll ultimately causing Phineas
to reject some of his own children a bit
later Phineas and Ursula birthed cygnus
belvina and Arcturus when he wasn't
conceiving children Phineas became a
professional teacher passing on all that
he had learned to the next generation of
wizards and witches his talents
eventually brought him to Hogwarts but
it's hard to know how effective he was
as a teacher when it comes to Black's
teaching style the record books simply
point out that he hated his job and he
hated the children that didn't stop him
from achieving success though as he
eventually Rose to the position of
Headmaster together with Ursula Phineas
created the only recognized heirs for
the black family through their marriage
elidora one of phineas's sisters was
also born in the years after the eldest
sirius's death unlike most of her
siblings elidora never found time to
create a family and perhaps due to her
modest contributions to the Black family
tree we don't really know that much
about her of the tales that survived
elidora's death none of them pained a
particularly flattering picture of the
wedge one record claims that elidora
created a cruel black family tradition
by tormenting ourselves of her many ways
of torturing the creatures sources claim
that elidora instituted a new rule if a
Hound self was unable to carry a tray of
tea she would Mount their head on a
wooden plaque and bolt them to the wall
the final member of this General
generation Biola Hitchens is perhaps the
most exciting she was the fourth black
sibling of the age and she broke the
most important rule she married a muggle
or muggleborn wizard the sources aren't
very clear much like her nephew who
Phineas the Elder would often debate
Iola didn't see the point in the black
family's obsession with the person's
pure blood status until the time of her
marriage
ayola most likely abided by the rules of
her family she probably received a
Wizarding education at Hogwarts and only
after that decided to marry her partner
Bob Hitchens since the pair were removed
from the Black family tree we don't know
if they ever had any children of their
own but it's most likely they did
whether or not any of their descendants
went on to rejoin the Wizarding
community in the following decades was
never answered but it's not hard to
imagine that iola's children or
grandchildren would have shown an
affinity for magic and as long as her
brother Phineas wasn't the Headmaster at
the time Iola would have likely allowed
her descendants to enroll the next
generation of blacks was solely
comprised of the children of Phineas and
Ursula's marriage there were four Sons
Sirius Black II Phineas Black II cygnus
Black and Arcturus black and a single
daughter belvina black beginning with
the eldest will find Sirius Black the
second as we mentioned previously he was
named after his uncle who tragically
died at just eight years of age unlike
his aunt iolas possible children Sirius
II was a pure blood wizard born in 1877
Sirius lived until the age of 75. when
he died of unknown reasons in the year
1952 his contributions to the family
line came in the form of two sons and a
daughter whom he hand with his wife
hesper camp and his line actually became
the longest lived while his siblings
descendants either passed without heirs
or were married off into different
families Sirius II's line produced males
to inherit the family name until the
1970s with the birth of the final black
boys Sirius III and regulus Finnish the
elders second son was named after
himself but Phineas Black II born in
1878 disappointed his father and
eventually got his name blasted off the
family tree like his aunt mayola Phineas
couldn't understand why his family was
so obsessed with pure blood status even
though his father was the Headmaster of
the very school he attended phineas's
time at Hogwarts likely only made
matters worse another famously
pro-muggleborn wizard was enrolled at
the very same time Albus Dumbledore
although there are any records of
massive student-led movements against
the pureblood ideology of the time it's
not unlikely that Phineas the younger
would have spent his days with
like-minded gryffindors instead of the
slytherins he probably lived with
Phineas II's younger brother Arcturus
blank was born over six years later in
1884 Arcturus married another pure blood
in the British Wizarding Community
lysandra yaxley although they weren't as
prolific as many of the other blacks the
pair raised three lovely daughters
kaladora cedrella and Karis one just
like her great aunt Iola fell in love
with someone the black family looked
down on ignoring her father's wishes
said drella went on to marry the man she
loved Septimus Weasley it's through this
bond that the Weasley family including
all of Arthur's children became
distantly related to Sirius Black III as
women the records for arcturus's
children weren't kept on the family tree
but each married into high-profile
Wizarding families while cedrela married
into the Weasleys her elder sister
caladora married ha Fang Longbottom
possibly linking Harry Potter's
classmate Neville to Sirius Black the
third sister Charis married Casper
Crouch and was probably related to the
Future Death Eater who shared the same
last name the next of Phineas the
First's children was belvina born in
1886. as another daughter in the Black
family tree she unfortunately was pushed
to the side of History although there
isn't much that we know about her we do
know that she got married to a pure
blood named Herbert Burke together they
had three children but the history books
stopped there the final member of
Phineas the first children was cygnus
black
born in 1889 he was also lucky enough to
see his father serve as Headmaster in
Hogwarts with his wife Violetta bolstrad
sickness fathered four children two sons
and two daughters cygnus's life was
fairly plain compared to his brothers
and sisters none of his children
committed a grave sin against the family
by marrying a muggle or muggleborn
however one of cygnus's children was
born without any magical abilities a
great shame for any pureblood family
cygnus went through great efforts to
hide this fact and even blast the name
of the child off the family tree when we
moved to the third generation of the
black family that's officially tracked
on their family tree will find that only
Sirius II's children and his brother
cygnus's children carry on the family
name as we mentioned earlier their
sister belvinus children weren't
documented and their brother Arcturus
only produced daughters if we look at
Sirius II's Children First we'll find
that his oldest Arcturus Black III was
born in 1901 and was alive during series
III's imprisonment in Azkaban in fact
Sirius Black was one of arcturus's two
grandchildren at some point after
attending Hogwarts octurus married a
pure blood witch named Melania MacMillan
their children Lucretia and Orion both
went on to marry purebloods as well
making their family proud when his
grandson Sirius Black talks about
Arcturus he reveals that his grandfather
must have been pretty wealthy as he was
able to bribe the ministry of magic for
an award although this might have been
said in jest it's still likely true
Sirius II's next child like chorus black
was born in 1904 and lived until 1965.
the reason for his very early death
wasn't given a reason but considering
she never married or produced children
the black family historians weren't
likely to devote too much to her life
like horus's birth was soon followed by
another in 1906 with the arrival of a
second son named regulus his name would
eventually be lent to sirius III's
brother like his older sister regulus
the first never married and never had
children at a time when marriage was
almost compulsory it's strange to see
that two members of Sirius II's
immediate family didn't go on to raise
any sons or Daughters of their own
moving on to the children of cygnus and
Violetta we'll discover how they became
relatives to belatrix Lestrange and even
Voldemort himself cygnus's eldest son
was Pollux black he was born in 1912 and
lived long enough to see The Wizarding
World condemn his descendant Sirius
Black for his supposed crimes his wife
Irma crab was important in bringing not
just the crabs but the lestrangers Tonks
and malfoys into the family line as well
cygnus's next child was a daughter named
Cassiopeia black records show she was
born in 1915. just three years after her
older brother Pollux and died in 1992
her skills in Witchcraft and was a dream
were nothing noteworthy and
unfortunately she didn't contribute much
to the legacy of the black family
alongside her other siblings however she
lived long enough to see the black
family name dragged through the mud as
their youngest generation joined the
Death Eaters and failed to bring
Voldemort to power not long after
cassiopeia's birth cygnus and his wife
Violetta had another son Marius you'll
notice that his name on the family tree
has been stricken out because just like
so many other members of his family he
betrayed the valley purebloods that the
blacks so dearly cherished but it wasn't
entirely his fault Marius was born
without an affinity for magic that meant
he never attended Hogwarts got the
chance to hear the Sorting Hat filter
him into how Southern or even wield a
wand the shame of his condition was so
great that the black family treated
young Marius as if he were a muggle or
Half-Blood they didn't even list his
wife or children in the official
genealogical records despite the fact
that his descendants could have very
well possessed magical powers of their
own after marius's birth his parents
were cautious about having another child
but in the year 1920 they celebrated the
birth of their fourth a witch named
Doria interestingly Doria went on to
marry a distant relation of Harry Potter
a pure blood wizard known as Charles
Potter who must have died before Harry's
own parents did as the dursleys were his
only known relative lives at the time
through Doria Harry was not only related
to Sirius Black but also the malfoys
Tonks crabs Weasleys and just about
every other prominent Wizarding family
in Britain now as we move towards the
Next Generation you'll notice something
we're getting closer and closer to the
most famous member of the black family
Sirius III if we start with the children
of Sirius Black II we'll find that
Arcturus was seemingly the first to
marry with his wife Melania MacMillan
Arcturus raised two children the first a
daughter named Lucretia was born in
1925. after attending Hogwarts and
making her parents proud as an
accomplished witch she went on to marry
a prominent wizard in the community a
Young Man known as Ignatius Pruitt
although Lucretia and Ignatius didn't
have any children of their own they were
deeply loved by the nieces and nephews
in fact Ignatius seemed to have a
particularly deep relationship with
Molly Weasley who would later go on to
fight against another member of her
family Bellatrix Lestrange Lucretia had
a younger brother about four years later
named Orion his life was relatively
short even by the black family standards
born in 1929 and dead by 1979 Orion was
remembered by his descendants as a
bitter deeply prejudiced old man he was
as tyrannical in his beliefs about
pureblood Supremacy as any other member
of his family tree and that's what drove
a wedge between him and his sons Sirius
Black III and regulus besides being
sirius's father Orion's other
contribution to the black family was in
making the tapestry a bit more
convoluted since he married a family
member a second cousin named woolberger
woolberger was the daughter of Pollock's
black and Irma Crabbe and one of the few
of of her generation to have children
born in 1925 she outlived her husband by
only a few years
woolberger's younger brother Alfred
black was another one of pollux's
children but he wasn't as well loved as
his sister he died in the late 70s and
instead of leaving his massive wealth to
his parents or his siblings he left most
of it to his nephew Sirius this strange
posthumous gift angered his relative so
much that woolburger blasted his name
off of the tapestry if you remember that
type of punishment was typically
reserved for blood traitors after Alfred
Pollux and Irma had a third and final
child sickness who they named after
pollux's father
through cygnus's children the black
family married into not only the Tonks
and malfoys but also produced an
illegitimate heir of Voldemort delphini
as we move on to the fifth and final
generation of the black family the
number of descendants has shrunk quite a
bit in fact of the five blacks of this
era only two were male and they died
before they were able to produce any
heirs ending the family name once and
for all the black family tradition of
quickly disowning their children as
blood traitors and ignoring the children
that their female descendants bore had
finally caught up with them if we turn
our attention to the Suns at Orion black
and his wife and cousin will Burger
produced will finally find the most
famous members of the family first in
1959 Sirius was born he was the third
male in his family to Bear the name but
rebelled against almost everything they
stood for sir serious was staunchly
opposed to his father's narrow view of
the world namely that only pure blood
Wizards deserved respect and fair
treatment one of his biggest acts of
rebellion was when he allowed the
Sorting Hat to suggest Gryffindor during
the selection process for centuries the
blacks had only enrolled in Slytherin
and Sirius was the only one to defy that
tradition later as many of his cousins
and relatives joined Voldemort's forces
Sirius rejected the movement ultimately
through a carefully orchestrated scheme
black was framed for horrendous crimes
and imprisoned in Azkaban when he
eventually escaped he briefly reunited
with his godson Harry Potter before
dying at the hands of his own cousin
Bellatrix Lestrange unlike Sirius
Orion's other sun regulus was initially
seduced by the dark wizards of his
generation for a brief time the younger
black brother joined the Death Eaters
and carried out their missions of
propaganda and violence shortly after
joining though regulus decided that the
Death Eaters were far too dangerous and
actively trying to sabotage them in his
final Act regulus track down one of
Voldemort's horcruxes but failed to
destroy it instead The inferi Who
surrounded the lake where the horcrux
was kept dragged regulars into the cold
Waters drowning him in the process when
we move on to cygnus Black III and his
children will find most of the families
involved in the final Wizarding War That
Shook Hogwarts to its foundations in the
late 90s zygnus's first child a daughter
was the evil wedge Bellatrix the strange
after graduating from Hogwarts Bellatrix
quickly joined the cult of Voldemort and
became a powerful Death Eater in his
army during campaigns for Voldemort
Bellatrix used her powerful dueling
skills to kill many of most prominent
opponents even though she was related to
most she didn't hesitate in butchering
them and among the many she murdered
Sirius Black and nymphadora Tonks stood
highest on a list in the end bellatrix's
end took a surprising turn when she was
defeated and killed by Molly Weasley
another one of her distant relations
although the Black family tree wouldn't
typically keep track of a female blacks
as bellatrix's single child was of
particular note her daughter named
delphini wasn't actually conceived with
her husband rodolf is the strange but
instead with Lord Voldemort himself
eventually delphini would challenge The
Wizarding World in the very same way her
father had some time after belatrix was
born her sister Andromeda came into the
world when we look at the Black family
tree we can easily see the familiar
black charred remains that surround her
picture which means that she too was
blasted off of the tapestry andromeda's
crime was falling in love with a
muggle-born wizard named Ted Tonks
although the family didn't recognize
them or their offspring andromeda's
marriage produced nymphadora Lupine a
powerful Aura and member of the Order of
the Phoenix in 1955 cygnus had a final
child another daughter this one was
named Narcissa and after attending
Hogwarts she married Lucius Malfoy
together they had a single son Draco and
briefly brought the power of the Elder
Wand into the family although Andromeda
Bellatrix and Narcissa had children and
grandchildren of their own the black
family ended with the deaths of regulus
and Sirius as both were the final male
heirs and both were childless and
perhaps that was for the best the rise
and fall of Lord Voldemort revealed many
flaws in the old way of thinking a line
of thought that the blacks seemed to
Value Above All Else their emphasis on
the importance of their name male heirs
and pure-blooded marriages was out of
place in the new world and even their
final Death Eater descendant Draco
Malfoy raised his children in a much
more Progressive fashion promoting the
inherent worth of all beings not just
those with pureblood heritage
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign